let's stick with the phones we'll go to
our next caller from the 75 for area
code 754 go ahead hello yes that's you
yeah all right yeah yeah okay um yeah um
Brock County and you know I've been a
registered you know Democrat voter says
2013 not turn 18 and you know currently
I'm looking at what's going on with
Democrat Party in the DNC and the DD CDC
and then I have a two-pronged question
about the state of the Democrat Party
and know its future yeah
and being a circus party so my question
is currently there's the Justice
Democrats and progressive democrats of
america i do you think those
organization will be able to like you
know change their card party into a more
effective progressive party and since to
actually you know pick up you know
million votes and pick up other glass
room votes I hope so I hope that they
are yeah of course I mean any any
movement that can successfully move the
Democratic Party to the left so that
it's more reflective of the policy
positions of the actual voters I think
is a good thing and if you're able to do
that without putting at risk and even
bigger Republican majority in some cases
or losing seats altogether to the
Republicans all the better so yeah I
hope that they are successful of course
okay all right the second the second
question would be if the jumped if you
know it's just a Democrat and in other
organizations are not able to get the
get get to push them that kind of party
like this damage is able to hold still
from 2018 to 2020 do you think no den
exist would be a real no likelihood of
happening - oh well yeah people have to
go to eat a green party or start a know
start the People's Party you know join
in with Nick Barrow know God and the
movement for Cuba's party you heard
right listen I don't think that it's
going to be a question of whether people
have to exit the Democratic Party and
run elsewhere I think it's going to be a
of we need ranked choice voting and
campaign finance reform in order to make
those viable alternatives so I would
approach it from a different way you're
sort of thinking about it from within
the Democratic Party and I think a lot
of these issues are sort of issues that
are outside of the Democratic Party and
I've talked about rank-choice voting
I've talked about you know
representative systems of Congress think
things that are not hugely likely to
happen anytime soon to be quite honest
with you but I think that there's
external factors that will sort of
dictate what the best strategy will be
within four to the left within the
Democratic Party okay all right thank
you all right really appreciate the call
we will take a quick break if you're
holding don't hang up because we will
continue taking calls right after this
break